SPEAKER: We're thrilled,
both as a company,
here at Google Ann
Arbor, and me personally
to welcome one of Detroit's
most high-profile and impactful
native sons, Jalen Rose, here
to Google, Ann Arbor today.
Jalen is known by, I
would assume, pretty much
all of you-- but Detroit
native, high school
at Detroit southwestern,
a school boy basketball
player who then came to
the University of Michigan.
Many of you know
the Fab Five, where
Jalen played with his buddies
here in the early '90s.
Jalen was then selected
in the 1994 NBA draft
and had a 13-year
career in the NBA.
I think one of the topics we'll
get into today, in some detail,
is what Jalen has done
after his life in the NBA--
both the impact and time
he spent in Detroit as well
as some of his thoughts
on-- [AUDIO OUT] --game
plan here is I'll ask him
questions for the first 30
minutes or so,
get Jalen to share
a little bit about
his perspective
as a Detroiter who's
gone on to stardom,
and then we'll make
sure to open it up
to questions in the second half
and take live questions here.
We'll have a mic that
we'll pass around.
Prior to start, give people
a little context for you.
Many of them know you from
your public profile today.
But a native Detroiter,
you were here
at the University of
Michigan in the early '90s,
which meant you were growing
up in Detroit in the '70s
and '80s.
Maybe you could just
give us a little context
for your experience
growing up and we'll
build towards your observations
of how Detroit has changed.
JALEN ROSE: So when you talk
about how things have changed
from like the '70s
and '80s until now,
the dynamic plays no further
than through education.
Because [INAUDIBLE]
describe, you
can actually have a
high school diploma
and get a really good job and
possibly make six figures.
Now, you have to have
a college degree.
That's basic.
And so in starting the Jalen
Rose Leadership Academy,
we're a tuition-free
public charter high school.
We're open enrollment.
We have 400 students
in the building.
We also graduated,
the last two years,
approximately 170 students.
And 100% of those
students went on
to a post-secondary education,
whether it's a university,
trade, or military.
And being a 9-16
model is not just
about getting these
kids at ninth grade
and graduating them
from high school.
It's actually staying with
them and nurturing them
through college.
Because that eight years,
to me, is the most important
eight years of your life.
It's the years where you
start to make decisions
that can impact your future.
But you're so very young.
And a lot of times,
you're making decisions--
making decisions at
17 or 18 that could
affect your long term future.
So we're really excited about
the progress of the school.
And we're committed
to try to do what
we can to educate as many
young people as possible
and put them in position to take
care of themselves and those
that they love.
SPEAKER: Great stuff.
On behalf of those of
us who are educated here
in the state of
Michigan, thank you
for your commitment to
education in the state.
JALEN ROSE: Well thing
that stinks actually-- I
saw a statistic that
approximately 12%
of Detroit area
adults have graduated
from college-- only 12%.
So when we get a lot
of our students--
and again I mentioned, we
are open enrollment, tuition,
free public charter--
all you have to do
is fill out the form.
What I'm trying to do is create
a private school environment
for public school kids
where they can all
compete in the same
collegiate classroom.
So unfortunately in
our country, education
has now been defined
by your zip code.
And we can mask and
act like it's not
happening the way it is or what
type of overtone or undertone
that it is.
But it does exist.
So for those parents like myself
that are really fortunate that
can put their kids
through private school,
that investment starts
at kindergarten.
So basically, K through 12, if
you're paying $30,000 a year,
that becomes an investment.
For those that are
fortunate enough to the move
to the suburbs, our country
dictates you pay more in taxes,
so your school
should be better even
though they're public schools.
So now if you look at
like West Bloomfield,
students get
$13,500 per student.
Plus for public school, they
also get gifted a building
for the students.
So in Detroit on
the Northwest side,
our students get
$7,100 per student.
So what I'm trying to do
is bridge the education gap
so that a kid, in theory,
that's getting $7,000 every year
invested in their education
can compete in the same college
classroom as the other two
scenarios I just described.
And that's the hard
work we do every day.
SPEAKER: I think
our friend Jalen
knows his educational
policy, huh guys?
JALEN ROSE: I'm the
founder of a school.
I only do a couple of things.
But only do things that I
think I'm pretty good at.
Like I don't play golf
because I'm not good at it.
I don't care about it.
I don't eat sushi.
I don't know why.
I just don't.
I mean, I don't use emojis.
I don't know why I don't.
I'm weird about certain things.
SPEAKER: Figure out what
you're good at and go deep.
JALEN ROSE: Yeah.
SPEAKER: That's a
good life philosophy.
JALEN ROSE: Don't get fired.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: There you go.
So it strikes me that
a lot about this school
is about setting up those
students for a lifetime
of achievement and success.
And part of that, the
leadership focus-- helping
prepare them for transitions.
We were talking a little bit
earlier-- a lot of our audience
is early career folk, some
of them in the first job.
You've been through transitions
in a really high profile way,
obviously going from
high school to college
and being on the basketball
court, and into the pros.
You've had situations where
you've had a coaching change
or something has
happened and you've
been thrown into a transition,
maybe not of your own making.
And maybe that's a little
bit like those of us here
who have a manager change where
it just sort of happens to us.
Maybe it wasn't our choice.
So as you think about
your path and your success
and how you tried to instill
in those Academy students--
Leadership Academy
students, the skills
to prepare for
transition, reflect
on transitions in your life.
Any thoughts on career and
transitions for this audience?
I love that pick a couple things
and do them really well piece.
JALEN ROSE: Absolutely.
Life skills are just as
important as being educated
and how you are able
to articulate yourself.
And if you think
you're not being
judged by of those things
and your appearance,
you need to wake up.
Because what you post on
social media, the people
that you surround yourself
with, when people bring you
in for an, interview they
already know this about you.
It's almost like
being a recruit.
When somebody comes
into my living room,
they know everything about me.
They know if we live
in a cul-de-sac,
they know if we have
a mailbox or not.
They know everything about
you before they allow you in.
The dynamic that I
learned [INAUDIBLE]
is, I've actually
had a lot of jobs.
I was one of the kids
that, when I was young--
and I know times are
a lot different now--
but I was somebody that,
when winter time came,
I would shovel the snow
in the front yard for $5,
front and back for $12, pick
an odd number so I can get 15
and keep $3--
[LAUGHTER]
Or pumping gas at
the gas station,
carrying bags at
the supermarket.
What other jobs did I have?
I've been a paper boy.
I was good too.
I would always put the paper
in the door, every time.
Even if it was cold outside.
SPEAKER: How early
were you doing that?
JALEN ROSE: Um-- 5:00,
6:00 in the morning.
SPEAKER: That's early.
JALEN ROSE: Yes indeed.
What are some of
the other job that I
want to share with you that-- I
was a police cadet one summer.
I worked at an envelope company.
I learned how to drive a hi-lo.
I actually have my hi-lo
license, true story.
SPEAKER: Right on.
JALEN ROSE: I
worked at Dave Bing
Steel for a couple of Summers.
And this was when I was in
high school, so it wasn't like,
oh Dave Bing played with my
dad and he's my godfather,
so he's looking out for me.
It was like, I'm on the press
and on the line with adults.
It's 5,000 pieces
of steel coming down
and you gotta be
meticulous with each one.
They don't care anything
about your mistakes.
Or if you hesitate a little
bit or you have to sneeze
or scratch your nose-- like
little things like that could
throw off an entire assembly.
And so I learned how to be
more detail oriented with that.
But the one thing you
have to learn how to do
is just manage relationships,
respect others,
and just be good at your job.
A lot of times in corporate
environments, people
get more caught up in
gossiping and worrying
about the opportunities
that other people get.
Just continue to nurture
the relationships.
And in sports, it's a little
different because normally
the person that drafted you or
the person that traded for you,
well they are going
to probably give you
more leeway to succeed
because we all have bad days.
When the opposite happens--
when you're in a position
and then there's a
management change,
you might want to
dust off your resume.
SPEAKER: [LAUGHS]
JALEN ROSE: No, I'm for real.
Like, you have to press Reset.
When the people
above you change,
you really have to press Reset.
Because they didn't hire you.
They didn't bring you in.
So they're not invested
in what you're going
to be able to do going forward.
So they may not have the type
of leash than the person who
initially brought you in.
So at JRLA, one of the things
we talk to young people about
is having life
skills, social skills,
we try to educate them
about etiquette and problem
solving, decision making,
sex, drugs, violence,
gang prevention.
When you're dealing
with high school kids,
they have the type
of issues that we
know exist on a daily
basis, good, bad, and ugly.
SPEAKER: Good advice.
Thank you for that perspective.
Some experience from transitions
and as a professional athlete.
That's good feedback for us.
So we have your book here.
We know you're an author
of a book recently.
And for those of us who
live in a digital world--
we'll come to some
questions about what
it's like to have a digital
presence today in a moment.
JALEN ROSE: This is
actually my second book.
It's just I don't get paid
anything for the first one.
[LAUGHTER]
You guys saw another
book that Mitch Albom
did on the Fab Five, right?
That became a best selling book.
SPEAKER: Yes it did.
JALEN ROSE: Well I love
Mitch, but I'm still
trying to get him to come
to one of our golf outings.
Still trying to get him
to sponsor a student.
OK?
I've done multiple
interviews on his platform.
And that book was
really successful.
And I'm happy that it was
written and the story got told.
I actually was so
upset that it happened,
I didn't read that book
until two years ago.
I wrote that book
before I wrote this one.
SPEAKER: Did that motivate
you to write this one?
JALEN ROSE: No.
I wanted to get
the clarity of what
he felt about what he was
seeing through his eyes,
as somebody that wasn't
necessarily in the foxhole,
versus my story where I know
all of the moving parts.
SPEAKER: So that's
a 15 or 20 year
lag between when that came
out and when you read it.
JALEN ROSE: Correct.
It was a couple of things.
The first thing was the
Fab Five documentary.
And so that came out in
2011-- March of 2011.
And I felt, as the executive
producer of the doc,
that it was time for us to
just unleash everything we
[INAUDIBLE] of the scenario.
And the next day, just
wake up and it's over.
And so that was the
thinking behind it.
I remember reaching out
to all of the fellas
to be a part of it,
and all of the coaches,
and all of the media
members that, any of you,
if you ever saw the documentary,
participated-- including Chris.
And so we tried to track him
down to get his interview.
He got kind of elusive,
then he decided
he didn't want to do it.
But like I told him,
whatever you still
harboring about that
situation, you gotta let it go.
You winnin' right now.
Like-- you got a good gig.
You know-- you have expanded
beyond that scenario, I think.
When you continue to
carry that burden,
it just kind of
becomes something
that you can't really escape.
And you need to just exhale.
But for whatever reason, he
chose not to participate.
That was a big time mistake.
And we continued
to go on and do it.
It was a successful documentary
It made a couple of people
upset.
But that's what happens
when you tell the truth.
But I was excited
about the project.
And so this really,
for me personally, it
was like the documentary,
read the Fab Five book
by Mitch Albom, and
then write my own book.
So I was doing a lot
of reading and writing.
I can actually do that.
SPEAKER: In our world here, we
might think somebody like you
from a 21st century, digital
profiles as a content creator.
You've created a documentary,
you've written a book,
obviously you spend
your profession
now with a lapel mic on you.
As somebody who's done those
sorts of things, what's
the biggest surprise for
you about writing a book
or reflecting on
the documentary?
When you're in your
voice out there
and you have full control, I
still imagine a couple bumps
along the way and surprises.
What surprised you
in these processes?
JALEN ROSE: Well, content that
you want people to accept,
it has to be genuine.
Like people see straight through
phony-- straight through it.
And so whether
it's a documentary,
whether it's a book, you
want to be authentic.
But one thing I actually do that
I always pretend I don't do,
I actually work hard.
SPEAKER: [CHUCKLES]
JALEN ROSE: No I'm serious.
I actually--
SPEAKER: I'm glad you pretend
that you don't do that.
JALEN ROSE: Well
because it's more fun.
And seriously, as a
former basketball player,
sometimes it's just
easier to play the heal.
It's just easier.
Hey, how you doing?
Nothing.
Oh whatever, ain't no big deal.
And show up and know
more than everybody.
Because I've been
doing it all morning.
So it's something
that people don't
realize that, at
Michigan, my major was
radio, TV, film-- communications
was actually my major.
So I'm probably the only person
in here working in their major?
Right?
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Certainly the only
one up here that can say that.
I can assure you.
JALEN ROSE: Ain't that
something how this works?
We go to school all of
those years, get a major,
and get a job doing
something else.
But I'm fortunate enough that
I actually work in my major.
So I also think that
gives me an advantage.
So while I was
playing ball, it was
2000 I was playing
in the NBA finals.
I get traded to
the Bulls in 2002.
I'm like, we ain't
going to the finals.
We only have nine wins
and it's February.
SPEAKER: As described in
the introduction book,
Jalen's thoughts on that matter.
JALEN ROSE: So I actually
did an interview--
I know I'm showing
my age here-- there
was BET Mad Sports at the time.
And so I did an
interview with them.
Somebody gave me a card--
I kept a business car.
I reached out to them.
And it was the Lakers and the
New Jersey Nets in the finals.
And I was like, I
got a spot in LA.
All you guys have to
do is send the camera.
I'll edit it.
I'll get us the access.
I'll do everything.
And then if you don't
like it, I'll just eat it.
If you like it, you play it.
And so I did it.
I did all of the interviews.
I got Shaq, I got Kobe, I got
Byron Scott, I got Jason Kidd,
I got everybody.
And so then they liked
it, used them to edit it,
because they got the budget,
they got the editing room.
OK?
So then once they did that, I
turned around and pitched that
to Fox and the Best
Damn Sports Show.
So from 2003 to 2007, I
was playing in the league,
but I was also working
for Best Damn Sports Show,
simultaneously.
So I was doing other
media gigs along the way.
SPEAKER: Seeing
both sides of it.
JALEN ROSE: Absolutely.
I worked sideline for TNT.
I worked with Shaq-- I mean,
I'm sorry, Shaq wasn't there--
but I worked with
Kenny and Charles, ABC
when they were doing their
halftime with Bill Walton,
a lot of ESPN appearances.
And so that gave
me the experience.
So in 2007, when I decided
to go full time in the media,
though I was a first-year
player removed from the league,
I was by far a rookie
in doing media stuff.
SPEAKER: You got
your apprenticeship
while you were still
doing the main gig.
JALEN ROSE: Yeah
this was my-- so that
was-- this was what, my 14th,
15th straight year covering
the finals for TV.
And there weren't
as many outlets
obviously then as it was now.
So there wasn't any NBA TV.
Sometimes the games were on NBC.
Sometimes the games were on ABC.
And that was it.
So it was really-- and ESPN.
So it probably was only
like 10 to 15 total jobs.
It wasn't a lot of jobs.
SPEAKER: I love that description
of just, send me the camera,
I can do it.
I mean if that doesn't
sound like a viral YouTube
video and the way some of our
YouTube stars become-- start
out, I mean that's what it is.
Right?
A guy on a camera
and I can do this.
And one thing led to another in
terms of your media presence.
JALEN ROSE: And also too is
the ability to multitask.
That's the one
thing that I think
young people should concentrate
on doing a better job of.
Because as I sit here
right now, if you
think about what I'm juggling--
so this is real time.
I'm possibly going
to do more episodes
of "To Tell The Truth" I
don't if you guys saw that
on ABC with Betty White and
Anthony Anderson-- Jalen
and Jacoby, which was a
podcast five years ago.
It became a radio show from 7:00
to 9:00 Eastern, September 28.
And then they
appreciated it so much,
they made it a television
show January 28.
We come on every
night on ESPN 2,
and every morning on ESPN News.
It's the off season for the NBA.
But I do ABC, "ESPN Countdown,"
in particular on weekends,
and on Sundays, and obviously
we had the NBA finals.
Which was a great NBA final
with Lebron James delivering
a championship to Cleveland.
So beyond that, I'm a dad,
I'm the founder of a school,
I'm a son, I'm a brother.
And so, juggling
all of those things
you have to be
efficient, but also you
have to have the
ability to multitask.
Because a lot of times
when you go down one path,
a lot of people get stuck.
So for me, it was
communications.
But it was radio, TV, and film.
SPEAKER: That's quite
an impressive set
of off-the-court accomplishments
and endeavors you've got going.
I'm going to ask
one more question
and then we'll open it up
to some live questions here.
We were reflecting before
the start that-- you know,
when you were in school in the
'90s-- in college for example,
in the early '90s, e-mail
was just getting going.
JALEN ROSE: We
had a floppy disk.
SPEAKER: We had floppy disks.
We were writing papers
with typewriters.
JALEN ROSE: And I was determined
not to use one for a while,
for some reason.
I was like, I'm not
using no floppy disk.
SPEAKER: And how
far you've come.
Now you're the doctor.
JALEN ROSE: I was like I
need to use a floppy disk.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: So it strikes me that
there was a huge pivot there
over the last 20 or so years.
You've talked a lot
about television
and your role in television.
But I think one of the
things that really makes you
the popular public figure
that you are is your candor.
I mean, you don't need me
to tell you this obviously.
You were talking about the
importance of authenticity
and candor earlier.
But with the explosion of
digital channels, social media
presence, blogs, the digital
uploads of your TV productions,
how do you think about how
to use technology today?
Online specifically,
you talked a little bit
about all your TV endeavors.
But I'm sure this group would
be interested in a little bit
about your thoughts
about online.
And then we'll open it
up to group questions.
JALEN ROSE: That's the
one thing in education
that-- so there are a lot of
things that make JRLA unique,
besides trying to
educate young people.
We know that if
you go to school,
you get your grades,
you graduate,
put yourself in the position
to go off to college,
and all of that.
But there's just as equal
a portion of a life skill
that you have to develop--
a leadership, which
is in our title.
So we have advisory
for our students.
We also have a leadership
course for our students.
We have multiple sports
and activities for students
to participate in.
The one thing that
schools and our government
do a horrible job of
legislating is social media
and how to teach young people
to use it to their benefit, not
their detriment.
That's exactly
what I say all day.
SPEAKER: And that's
what you were
talking about earlier--
once it's out there,
it's tough to undo.
JALEN ROSE: Correct.
And so your social media
presence is now the new resume.
That's exactly what it is.
So what I do with
my presence, I make
people feel like
they're following
exactly what I'm doing.
But I don't want people to know
where I'm at all of the time.
I don't necessarily want
people to know what city I'm
in all of the time.
So what I do, I more use social
media, either professional
or personal.
That's it.
There was a time when people
would say negative comments.
I would fire back--
nah, just block 'em.
Like if somebody would even
think about saying something
negative, I'd just block 'em.
But here is why.
Your social media
is your timeline.
So why am I going to have
somebody on my timeline,
disrespecting me.
That doesn't make sense.
It's almost like you
disrespected me in my home.
It doesn't make sense.
And it takes so much-- negative
energy takes so much from you.
It just [LOUDLY EXHALES]
And so, everybody's
not rooting for you.
Here's another thing
on social media.
Everybody's not rooting
for your success.
Everybody doesn't
want you to see
you have your dream
job, your dream car,
see you buy your mom a house.
Everybody does not
want that for you.
And so a term I
got from my sister
that I always use is, people
come into your life for four
reasons-- to add,
subtract, multiply,
or divide-- choose wisely.
And that's my approach
to social media.
I'm giving you the information
I want you to have, not
the other way around.
So I'll go and see
what's trending
or what may be a breaking
news story or whatnot.
But usually when I'm
tweeting something,
it's I'm tweeting to the
audience, not necessarily
the other way around
I do read my mentions.
I do follow what's
happening on social media.
I was somebody that back in
the day, I had a Myspace page.
I have a YouTube page.
But eventually,
I remember taking
all of the time and energy
to make sure my albums
and my pictures look
right on Myspace page.
And I clicked on it one
day and it was gone.
Like, I spent so much time
and energy on this page.
Then when technology
changes, it all goes away.
So use it as a tool but not as
something that all of a sudden,
you find yourself muscle
memory looking down
at your phone 50 times a day.
Because that takes energy to do.
You don't realize-- just test
yourself, how many times am I
looking down at my phone today?
SPEAKER: I believe we've got
stats on that one for you.
We can set you up with
some folks later today
if you want to know a
little more about that.
[LAUGHTER]
JALEN ROSE: And I'm
looking at this audience.
So let me just say this.
Please raise your hand
if you have all three
of these-- Twitter,
Instagram, and or Snap.
SPEAKER: Twitter,
Instagram, and or Snap?
JALEN ROSE: Right.
SPEAKER: Most of the audience.
JALEN ROSE: So just
think about it.
That's three different
sites that you're
keeping current all day.
That's a job.
[LAUGHTER]
That's really taking
your time and energy.
That takes a lot
of time and energy.
The other thing I do with
social media-- and part of it
is my age.
I am getting older,
so I can't be doing
everything the cool kids do.
I don't want to.
I know I'm not one.
SPEAKER: You might be selling
yourself a little bit short
there, but that's
just my point of view.
JALEN ROSE: So like,
I pick and choose
the mediums I want
to participate in.
So when Twitter came out
initially I was like,
I don't want to participate.
Then I was like,
all right, cool.
I can get into that.
And I did it.
When Instagram came out
I was like, I'm good.
Pictures?
I'm Good.
No, I am good.
Picture's worth a
thousand words--
I don't want people tagging
me on pictures sometimes.
And so when it first
came out, I decided
I didn't want to
be a part of it.
And so now when the
other things come,
like Periscope or Snapchat,
I already just made my mind,
I'm not dealing with 'em.
But I could get the same
thing accomplished on Twitter.
I could post a video,
I could post a message,
you can make a longer link now.
So I don't have to go to
three or four different sites
to get out the same message.
And also you're
dividing your followers.
You're dividing your message.
You might have 200 people
following you here,
400 people following
you here-- like
imagine if you were able
to consolidate that.
SPEAKER: It's back to one
of your earlier points--
take a few things and
do them really well.
JALEN ROSE: Correct.
So that's my approach
to social media.
SPEAKER: Alright.
Well hopefully that provided--
JALEN ROSE: And this is my
little brother and I love him.
But I have to throw
a social media shout
because I'm near the
University of Michigan.
And we saw my brother
Draymond Green, the post
that he did on Snapchat.
[LAUGHTER]
You know what I'm saying?
I didn't see the picture.
Heard it wasn't his best
performance-- best work.
[LAUGHTER]
I didn't see that picture.
I'm just saying.
So those are the type of
things though that can-- see,
he's an all-star
basketball player.
So you know what's going
to happen when he does his.
He didn't commit a crime.
His job's going to say he's one
of the best at what he does.
No big deal-- when
does Team USA practice.
But that happened to you?
You're going to get fired.
And so that is the
tug-of-war that
truly happens with social media
that you have to be careful.
I've been influencing young
people via scholarship
through public schools
since about 2002.
We influenced around 40 kids.
And really just, JRLA became
a graduation of that mission.
I never thought that
I'd be the founder
of a charter high school.
You guys ever saw
me play in college,
I know y'all didn't ever think
I'd be the founder of a charter
high school.
So now for young people,
they unfortunately
get a chance to get so
exposed to adult situations
early-- the language,
the nudity-- you
go through the guide,
boom, "Dating Naked."
Like seriously, it's an
actual show on television.
Like how can you seriously
date somebody naked?
[LAUGHTER]
You know what I mean?
SPEAKER: We got a whole
different set of considerations
on these topics as
parents today, right?
JALEN ROSE: Right?
But behind that is
an undercurrent of,
the young people are
listening and watching.
So when I was young and
my favorite artist cursed,
I could just hide
the tape from my mom.
Where now, it's on the radio.
Now they're cussing
on television.
Now you get a chance to see more
nudity and things like that.
So you have young people--
you know, 8 through 15--
being exposed to these
situations-- and drugs also.
Vaping, smoking,
drinking, lean, perks,
zans-- everything
Future raps about.
Whatever Future rap about.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
Whatever he raps about.
And so now you throw that in.
So you've got social
media, you have
what they're being
exposed to, and now
you have a young mind,
just 16 years old,
just so much happening.
And so now you
throw social media
in there, that becomes
a volatile cocktail.
SPEAKER: Indeed it does.
Social media Do's and
Don'ts from Jalen Rose.
How good is that, huh?
Alright, we're
going to open it up
to questions from
the live audience.
A couple things
that I loved-- we've
got a mic that will
start circulating here.
A couple pearls of
wisdom from Jalen
that really resonated with
me-- "Find a couple things you
do really well, and
do them really well,"
"Have fun, maybe
have a lot of fun,
but then [INAUDIBLE]
that hard work."
I like that play
the heal comment,
and then make it happen.
I loved the send
me the camera line.
To me that was so representative
of the power of digital today.
Just send me the
camera and I can do it.
And I will prove it to you.
And look at what's
happened since in terms
of Jalen's broadcasting career.
And then I loved the advice
from your family member
about four reasons people are
in your life-- their's add,
subtract, multiply, or divide.
Choose those folks
wisely as you think
about who you want
to let in and how
they're going to influence you.
So with that, to paraphrase
the title of your book,
let's give the
people what they want
and nothing about my questions.
Let's go to the audience.
AUDIENCE: Hi Jalen, we actually
have a lot of former teachers,
surprisingly, in this office.
JALEN ROSE: Oh great.
AUDIENCE: And then we also
have-- I know a ton of people
with a heart for the
surrounding community.
JALEN ROSE: We're looking
for a forensics teacher
and an algebra teacher.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm founder of a school.
AUDIENCE: What I was
specifically wondering is,
are there any partnership
opportunities for needs
that the JRLA might have?
JALEN ROSE: I think
one of the main needs,
if we have a lot
of teachers in here
that want to influence our
students, would be tutor.
Because we're sending young
people home with lessons,
at some point, like you
did with your parents,
that they can't help you with.
And so any tutoring
really helps.
Any mentoring really helps.
Because young people
need that guidance,
they appreciate that support.
So those would be probably
the two main things.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Jalen.
JALEN ROSE: Thank you for
making sure I was good
when I got here today.
AUDIENCE: You know I
got you man, I got you.
Full service here.
Thanks again for coming.
I read your book-- it's awesome.
I found very interesting the
part where you also you talk
about growing up a have not.
And then slowly,
your eyes are opening
to what's happening--
what other people have.
So your school is
high school-- you
say that the eight years from
high school to college-- those
are probably the most important
years of your life, when
you become a man, a woman.
Coming from an impoverished
background myself,
it's kind of easy to,
once your eyes are open,
to fall into an
nihilistic viewpoint--
like, there's no way
I'm going out here.
How-- what-- what
am I trying to say?
At your school, how can you
go about teaching young people
to not fall into that trap?
Does that make sense?
JALEN ROSE: Absolutely.
You have to be a leader,
stop making excuses.
Those two things
go hand in hand.
In my life, I try
to divide things
between reasons and excuses.
Some things, you can't control.
Now there is an inherent
thing that finance
creates that puts you in a
position to where now you
live in an impoverished
neighborhood, which sends you
to a poor-performing school.
Your parents probably
don't have the jobs
that they hoped that
they would have.
They probably don't
have the outlook
that you would deem that's
a normal background to raise
young people to be successful.
You have a lot of [INAUDIBLE]
a lot of single parent homes.
So at some point
in your life, you
have to start taking
responsibility for you.
And I think that really
starts around ninth grade.
Because only so long you
can blame your uncle,
you can blame your mom, you
can blame your circumstance.
When you have a chance now
to fix your circumstance.
And for young people,
your report card
is your paycheck when
you're in high school.
That's the equivalent to an
adult working-- you showing up
to school every day, you
taking care of your lessons,
you're taking care
of your grades.
Try to get you a summer job.
Try to keep your nose clean.
Surround yourself with
responsible, disciplined
people.
So these are decisions you
can make in ninth great.
I remember being in ninth grade.
And all of those
things were there.
There were people smoking,
there people having sex,
there were people
drinking, there were
all of those things happening.
But at some point,
you have to decide,
is that going to take you away
from your dreams or your goals?
And when your goals become
the most important thing--
not to your mother or father,
not to your coach your mentor--
but when your dreams become
the most important thing
to you, then to
me, that puts you
on a path to actually
try to pursue them.
SPEAKER: Well we love
that Jalen has taken us
to overtime here today to
demonstrate his passion--
[LAUGHTER]
--for education in
southeastern Michigan.
Jalen, again, thank
you so much for coming.
JALEN ROSE: Thank you
guys for having me.
[APPLAUSE]